(narrator) With the Google Pay API
for Android,
you can facilitate
payment transactions for your users,
making the checkout experience
in your application more convenient.
Join other businesses like yours
who are using Google Pay today
to drive user growth,
increase conversions,
and reduce data exposure
and transaction vulnerabilities.
Here is how you can integrate Google Pay
on your Android application
in four simple steps:
configure your project;
determine readiness to pay;
show the Google Pay button;
create a PaymentDataRequest object.
First, add the Google Pay library
to the list of dependencies
in your application module.
Make sure to review our documentation
to check the latest version available.
You also need to enable
the Google Pay API in your manifest.
You can do that by adding
the following tag
inside of your application node.
As soon as you are ready,
open the activity where you plan
to show the Google Pay button
and obtain a new instance
of the paymentsClient
inside of your onCreate method.
Note that the getPaymentsClient method
takes a walletOptions parameter.
Use the definitions in this class
to specify the environment
in which you want to operate,
TEST or PRODUCTION.
For the TEST environment,
you don't need to register with Google.
You can play with the API yourself
and integrate into your application.
In this case, you can use
real payment information.
However, whenever a selection is made,
we return you a non-chargeable token.
Remember, your real card details
are never used when in Environment test,
but you must add at least one
chargeable card to your Google account
before you proceed.
Once you complete the integration
and you are ready to handle real payments,
come and register with us
through our self-service portal
and then flip the environment
to PRODUCTION.
You can apply for production access
on g.co/pay/sign-up
Now that you have
your paymentsClient constructed,
the first API you need to call
is IsReadyToPay.
With IsReadyToPay
you can determine whether the user
has a valid payment method on file
and is capable of completing
a transaction on a supported device.
This request takes parameters
that specify the API version
targeted in your call,
as well as the payment methods
allowed for this transaction.
At Google, we focus
on optimizing for conversions,
so if IsReadyToPay returns false,
we highly recommend
that you do not show
the Google Pay button.
Now that you know that the user is ready
to make a payment using Google Pay,
you can make the button
visible to the user.
We recommend that you use the graphic
shared in the developer documentation
to ensure the Google Pay branding
is used correctly
per our latest guidelines.
In this bundle,
you will find drawable
and layout resources
that adapt to different screen sizes
and resolutions,
as well as translations
into multiple languages
for the text in the button.
Once the user taps on the button,
you call the loadPaymentData(request)
to open up the payment sheet.
You can construct
the PaymentDataRequest object
which is a set of payments configurations
used for this particular transaction.
You can request additional information,
like a shipping address and email address,
in addition to the payment credentials.
We recommend that you collect
as little information as necessary
to prevent users
from typing additional information
which might not be stored
in their accounts.
One more point to call out in this object
is the PaymentRequest
tokenization parameters.
Google encrypts information
about a user's selected card
for secure processing
by a merchant's gateway
or directly on
a merchant's secured servers.
Be sure to check
your processor's integration guidelines
to find out what they need
to finalize the payment.
Now that you've constructed
the request object,
you can pass it to loadPaymentData--
an asynchronous task
which opens the payments sheet.
Once the user makes a selection,
we return to you a PaymentData object
as an activity result,
which consists of metadata
about the user's selection.
It also includes the payment token
which you can use
to complete the transaction.
Now you can send the final
production-ready application to Google
for a final test.
Google tests the app with real cards
and informs you if everything is correct.
The app is then cleared to launch.
You can find additional information
in our developer documentation
on g.co/pay/api
Don't miss any future videos
about Google Pay and Android,
and subscribe
to the Android Developers channel.
If you are watching on a mobile,
tap the little bell
to receive new upload notifications.
See you soon!